The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Any questions
from last lecture
from before spring break?
No questions, nothing?
Nothing at all?
We you all still on vacation?
Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk
about coherence states?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
OK, well, that's
a great question.
So coherence states--
actually, how many people
have looked at the
optional problems?
Nice, OK, good.
Good, so coherence
states were a topic
that we touched on
the problem sets
and on the optional problems,
and the optional problems
are mostly on the harmonic
oscillator and nice problems
revealing some of the structure
of the harmonic oscillator,
and it generalizes quite boldly.
But here's the basic
idea of coherence states.
Let me just talk you
through the basic ideas
rather than do any calculations.
So what's the ground state
of a harmonic oscillator?
What does its wave
function look like?
AUDIENCE: Gaussian.
PROFESSOR: It's a
Gaussian, exactly.
It's minimum
uncertainty wave packet.
How does it evolve in time?
AUDIENCE: Phase.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, phase.
It's an energy eigenstate,
it's the ground state,
so it just evolves in
time with the phase.
So if we look at the wave
function for the ground
state, phi naught, it's
something like e to the minus x
squared over 2a squared with
some normalization coefficient,
which I'm not going
to worry about.
So this is a minimal
uncertainty wave packet.
Its position distribution
is time independent,
because it's a
stationary statement.
It's momentum distribution,
which is also a Gaussian,
the Fourier transform,
is time independent.
And so this thing up to its
rotation by the overall phase
just sits there and
remains a Gaussian.
Now, here's a question.
Suppose I take my harmonic
oscillator potential,
and I take my Gaussian, but
I displace it a little bit.
It's the same ground
state, it's the same state
but I've just displaced
it over a little.
What do you expect to happen?
How will this state
evolve in time?
So, we know how to
solve that problem.
We take this state, it's a
known wave function at time 0.
We expand it in the basis
of energy eigenstates,
each energy eigenstate
evolves in time with a phase,
so we put in that
phase and redo the sum,
and recover the time
evolution of the full state.
And we've done this a number
of time on the problem sets.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would the Gaussian,
the displaced Gaussian
evolve the same
way, keep its width,
if it had any
other initial width
other than the one
of the ground state?
PROFESSOR: Let me
come back to that,
because it's a little more
of a precise question.
So we know how to solve
this problem practically,
algorithmically.
But here's a nice fact.
I'm not going to derive
any equations, that's
part of the point of
the optional problems,
but here's a nice
fact about this state.
So it's clearly a minimum
uncertainty wave packet
because at time 0,
because it's just
the same Gaussian just
translated over a little bit.
So what we'd expect,
naively, from solving
is we expand this
in Fourier modes
and then we let this the
system evolve in time.
We let each individual
Fourier mode--
or, sorry, Fourier mode-- we
let each individual energy
eigenstate evolve in time, pick
up a phase, and now what we get
is a superposition.
Instead of sum over
n at time 0, we'd
have sum over n cn phi n of x.
Now, as a function of time,
we get e minus I omega nt,
and these phases are going
to change the interference
from summing up all
these energy eigenstates,
and so the system
will change in time.
Because the way that the various
terms in the superposition
interfere will change in time.
So very naively, what you
might expect, if you just
took a random
function-- for example,
if I took a harmonic
oscillator potential
and I took some stupid function
that did something like this.
What would you expect
it to do over time?
Well, due to all the complicated
interference effects,
you'd expect this to turn
into, basically, some schmutz.
Just some crazy
interference pattern.
The thing that's nice
about a coherent state,
and this is where
it gets its name,
is the way that all of
these interference effects
conspire together to evolve
the state is to leave it
a Gaussian that does nothing
but translates in time.
A coherent state is coherent
because it remains coherently
a Gaussian as it moves along.
It oscillates back and forth.
And in fact, the peak, the
center of this Gaussian wave
packet, oscillates with
precisely the frequency
of the trap.
It behaves just as a classical
particle would have had you
displaced it from the center of
the harmonic oscillator trap,
it oscillates back and forth.
Now, on the other hand,
you know that its momentum
is changing in time, right.
And at any given
point, as you've
shown on the problem set
that's due tomorrow--
or you will have shown-- at
any given moment in time,
the momentum can be understood
as the overall phase.
You could just change that
momentum by the overall phase,
so it's the spatial rate
of change of the phase, e
to the ikx.
So you know that the way the
phase depends on position
is changing over time.
So it can't be quite so simple
that the wave function, rather
than the probability
distribution,
is remaining a
Gaussian over time.
It's not, it's got all
sorts of complicated phases.
But the upshot is that the
probability distribution
oscillates back and forth
perfectly coherently.
So that seems a little
magical, and there's a nice way
to understand how
that magic arises,
and it's to understand
the following.
If I take a state, phi 0, but
I translate it x minus x0.
OK.
So we know that this
state, phi 0 of x,
was the ground
state, what does it
mean to be the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator?
How do I check if
I'm the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator?
Look, I walk up to
you, I'm like, hey,
I'm the ground state of
the harmonic oscillator.
You're suspicious.
What do you do?
AUDIENCE: Annihilate.
PROFESSOR: Annihilate.
Exactly.
You act with the
annihilation operator.
Curse you.
So you act with the annihilation
operator and you get 0, right.
What happens if I act with the
annihilation operator on this?
Is this the ground state?
No, it's been displaced by x0.
And meanwhile, I told you that
it oscillates back and forth.
So what happens if you act
with the annihilation operator?
Should you get 0?
No, what are you going to get?
AUDIENCE: Something weird.
PROFESSOR: Some
random schmutz, right?
If you just take a and you
act on some stupid state,
you'll just get some
other stupid state.
Except for Gaussians
that have been displaced,
you get a constant
times the same wave
function, phi 0 of x minus x0.
Aha.
It turns out that these
displaced Gaussians
are eigenstates of the
annihilation operator.
What does that mean?
Well, it means they're
coherent states.
And so the optional
problems are a working
through of the study
of the eigenfunctions
of the annihilation operator,
the coherent states.
Is that cool?
It's a state, it's
a superposition.
You can think
about it like this.
It's a superposition of
the energy eigenstate.
Any state is a superposition
of energy eigenstates,
and a coherent state is
just some particularly
special superposition
of energy eigenstates.
So you can think about
it literally as c0 phi
0 plus c1 phi 1 plus c2
phi 2, blah blah blah.
What does the
annihilation operator
do, what does the
lowering operator do?
It takes any state
and then lowers it
with some coefficient.
So a coherent state, an
eigenstate of the annihilation
operator, must be a
state such that if you
take c 0 phi 0 plus
c1 phi 1 plus c2 phi 2
and you hit it with the
annihilation operator, which
will give you see c1 phi 0 plus
c2 phi 1 divided by root 2 plus
dot, dot, dot-- or times
root 2 plus dot, dot, dot.
It gives you the
same state back.
So that gave you a relation
between the coefficients c0
and c1, c1 and c2, c2 and c3.
They've all got to be suitable
multiples of each other.
And what you can show-- and this
is something you work through,
not quite in this order, on
the optional problems-- what
you can show is that
doing so it gives you
a translated Gaussian.
OK.
So physically, that's
what a coherent state is.
Another way to say what
a coherent state is,
it's as close to
a classical object
as you're going
to get by building
a quantum mechanical
wave function.
It's something that behaves
just like a classical particle
in that potential
would have behaved,
in the harmonic
oscillator potential.
Did that answer your question?
OK.
Anything else?
So, Matt works with
these for a living.
Matt, do you want
to add anything?
All right.
I like these.
They show up all over the place.
This is like the spherical
cow of wave functions
because it's awesome.
It's an eigenfunction, it's
an annihilation operator,
it behaves like a
classical particle.
AUDIENCE: Is there an easy
way to define coherent states
in potentials where you don't
have nice operators like a?
PROFESSOR: No, I
mean, that's usually
what we mean by
a coherent state.
So the term coherent state
is often used interchangeably
to mean many different
things, which
in the case of the harmonic
oscillator, are identical.
One is a state
which is a Gaussian.
OK.
So in the harmonic
oscillator system,
that's a particularly nice
state because it oscillates
particularly nicely and it
maintains its probability
distribution as a function of
time roughly by translating,
possibly, some phases.
But people often use the
phrase coherent state
even when you're not harmonic.
And it's useful to keep in mind
that we're often not harmonic,
nothing's truly harmonic.
You had another question
a moment ago though,
and your question
was about the width.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It just translates
without changing its width,
with or without changing
its shape at all.
If the Gaussian were
of a different width,
would that still happen?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it does,
although the details of how
it does so are
slightly different.
That's called a squeeze state.
The basic idea of a
squeeze state is this.
Suppose I have a
harmonic oscillator--
and this is actually
one way people
build squeeze
states in labs-- so
suppose I have a
harmonic oscillator
and I put the system
in a ground state.
So there's its ground state.
And its width is correlated with
the frequency of the potential.
Now, suppose I
take this potential
at some moment in time and
I control the potential,
the potential is created by
some laser field, for example.
And some annoying grad student
walks over to the control panel
and doubles the
power of the laser.
All of a sudden, I've
squeezed the potential.
But my system is already in
a state which is a Gaussian,
it's just the wrong Gaussian.
So what does this guy do?
Well, this is funny.
The true ground state,
once we've squeezed,
the true ground state
would be something
that's much narrower
in position space.
I didn't draw that
very well, but it
would be much narrower
in position space,
and thus its
distribution would be
much broader in momentum space.
So the state that
we put the system,
or we've left the system in, has
too much position uncertainty
and too little
momentum uncertainty.
It's been squeezed compared
to the normal state
in the delta x delta p plane.
It's uncertainty relation
is still extreme,
it still saturates the
uncertainty bound because it's
a Gaussian, but it doesn't have
the specific delta x and delta
p associated with
the true ground
state of the squeezed potential.
OK, so now you can ask what
does this guy do in time.
And that's one of the
optional problems, too,
and it has many of the nice
properties of coherent states,
it's periodic, it evolves much
like a classical particle,
but it's uncertainties
are different
and they change shape.
It's an interesting story,
that's the squeezed state.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do other
potentials have
coherent states
that are Gaussian?
PROFESSOR: It sort of depends.
So other potentials have
states that behave classically.
Yeah.
There are generally-- so
systems that aren't the harmonic
oscillator do have very
special states that
behave like a
classical particle.
But they're not as
simple as annihilations
by the annihilation operator.
Come to my office
and I'll tell you
about analogous
toys for something
called supersymmetric
quantum models,
where there's a
nice story there.
OK.
I'm going to cut off coherent
states for the moment
and move on to where we are now.
OK, so last time we
talked about scattering
of a particle, a quantum
particle of mass m
against a barrier.
And we made a
classical prediction,
which I didn't quite
phrase this way.
But we made a
classical prediction
that if you took this
particle of mass m
and threw it against a
barrier of height v0,
that the probability
that it will transmit
across this barrier to
infinity is basically 0.
So this is the
classical prediction.
It will not transmit to
infinity until the energy goes
above the potential.
And when the energy is above the
potential, it will slow down,
but it will transmit
100% of the time.
So this is our
classical prediction.
And so we sought to solve
this problem, we did.
It was pretty straightforward.
And the energy eigenstate
took the form-- well,
we know how to
solve it out here,
because these are just
constant potentials
so it's just plain waves.
Let's take the
case of the energy
is less than the potential.
So this guy.
Then out here, it's in a
classically disallowed state,
so it's got to be a exponential.
If we want it to be
normalized, well, we
need it to be a
decaying exponential.
Out here it's
oscillatory, because it's
a classically allowed region.
And so the general form of the
wave function of the energy
eigenstate is a superposition
of a wave moving this way
with positive momentum, a
wave with negative momentum,
a contribution with
minus k, and out here it
had to be the
decaying exponential.
And then by matching, requiring
that the wave function was
oscillatory and then
exponentially decaying out
here, and requiring that it was
continuous and differentiably
continuous-- that its
derivative was continuous--
we found matching
conditions between
the various
coefficients, and this
was the solution in general.
OK.
Now, in particular,
this term, which
corresponds to the component
of the wave function moving
towards the barrier on the left
hand side, has amplitude 1.
This term, which corresponds
to a wave on the left
with negative momentum,
so moving to the left,
has amplitude k minus i
alpha over k plus i alpha,
where h bar squared
k squared upon 2m
is equal to-- that's just the
energy, e-- and h bar squared
alpha squared over 2m--
that's on this side-- is
equal to v0 minus e.
But this, notably,
is a pure phase.
And we understood that, so
we'll call this parameter r,
because this is
the reflected wave
and this is an amplitude
rather than a probability,
so we'll call it little r.
And we notice that
the probability
that we get out-- good.
So if we want to ask
the question, what
is the transmission probability,
the probability that I get
from far out here to far out
here, what is that probability?
So if I consider a state that
starts out as a localized wave
packet way out here and I
send it in but with energy
below the barrier,
what's the probability
that I'll get
arbitrarily far out here,
that I will subsequently find
the particle very far out here?
0, right, exactly.
And you can see that because
here's the probability
amplitude, the norm
squared is the probability
density as a function
of the position.
And it goes like a constant
times e to the minus alpha x.
For large x, this
exponential kills us.
And we made that more precise
by talking about the current.
We said look, the
current that gets
transmitted is equal to-- that's
a funny way to write things.
H bar-- sorry.
The current that
gets transmitted,
which equal to h bar upon
2mi psi complex conjugate dx
psi minus psi dx psi complex
conjugate on the right.
So we'll put right,
right, right, right.
This is just equal to
0, and the easiest way
to see that is
something you already
showed on a problem set.
The current vanishes
when the wave function
can be made real up to a phase.
And since this is some
number, but in particular it's
an overall constant
complex number,
and this is a real
wave function,
we know that this is 0.
So the transmitted
current out here is 0.
The flux of particles moving
out to the right is 0.
So nothing gets
out to the right.
So that was for the energy
less than the potential,
and we've now
re-derived this result,
the classical prediction.
So the classical prediction
worked pretty well.
Now, importantly,
in general, we also
wanted to define the
transmission probability
a little more
carefully, and I'm going
to define the
transmission probability
as the current of
transmitted particles
on the right divided by the
current of probability that
was incident.
And similarly, we can
define a probability
that the particle
reflects, which
is the ratio of the reflected
current, the current
of the reflected beam,
to the incident current.
So this is going to be the
transmission probability
and the reflection probability.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a square on t?
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
OK.
So let's do a slightly
different example.
In this example, I want to
study the same system, the wall,
but I want to consider
a ball incident
from the left-- a ball.
An object, a quantum particle
incident from the left,
with energy greater
than v. Greater than v0.
So again, classically, what
do you expect in this case.
You send in the particle, it
loses a little bit of energy
going up the potential
barrier, but it's still
got a positive kinetic energy,
and so it just keeps rolling.
Just like my car making
it up the driveway,
just barely makes it.
OK.
So here again, what's the
form of the wave function.
Phi e can be put in
the form on the left.
It's going to be e to the
ikx plus b to the minus ikx,
and that's over
here on the left.
And on the right it's
going in the form ce
to the ik-- in fact, let me call
this k1x and k2x-- or sorry,
k1x, which is on the left.
H bar squared k1 squared
upon 2m is equal to e.
And on the right, we're going
to have k2x because it's, again,
a classically
allowed region, it's
going to be oscillatory but
with a different momentum.
e to the ik2x plus
de to the minus ik2x
where h bar squared
k2 squared upon 2m
is equal to e minus v0,
which is a positive number,
so that's good.
So here's our wave function.
Now, before we do
anything else, I
want to just interpret
this quickly.
So again, this is like a wave
that has positive momentum,
and I'm going to say that it's
like a contribution, a term
in the superposition, that
is moving to the right,
and the way to think of it
as moving to the right, well,
first off, it's got
positive momentum.
But more to the point, this
is an energy eigenstate.
So how does this
state evolve in time?
It's an energy
eigenstate with energy,
how does it evolve in time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It rotates by
an overall phase, exactly.
So we just get this
times an e to the minus
i omega t, where h bar omega
is equal to e, the energy.
And that's true on
the left or right,
because the energy
is just a constant.
So this term goes as
e to the ikx minus i
omega t, or kx minus omega t.
And this is a point
of constant phase
in this move to the right.
As t increases-- in order
for the phase to be constant
or for the phase, for example,
to be 0-- as t increases,
x must increase.
By assumption here, k
is a positive number.
On the other hand, this guy--
that was a k1-- the second term
is of the form e
to the minus ik1x,
and when I add the omega
t, minus i omega t,
this becomes kx plus omega t.
So point of constant
phase, for example, phase
equals 0, in order for this to
stay 0 then, as t increases,
x must become negative.
x must decrease.
So that's why we
say this corresponds
to a component of
the wave function,
a term in the superposition
which is moving to the left.
And this is one which
is moving to the right.
Sorry, my right, your left.
Sorry, this is
moving to your right
and this is moving to your left.
OK?
It's that little z2, it's
harder than it seems.
OK.
In this set up, we could
imagine two different kinds
of scattering experiments.
We can imagine a
scattering experiment
where we send in a particle from
the left and ask what happens.
So if you send in a
particle from the left,
what are the logical
possibilities?
AUDIENCE: It can go through.
PROFESSOR: It could
go through, or?
AUDIENCE: Reflect back.
PROFESSOR: Reflect back.
Are you ever going to get a
particle spontaneously coming
from infinity out here?
Not so much.
So if you're sending a
particle in from the left,
what can you say about
these coefficients?
d equals 0 and a
is not 0, right.
Because d corresponds to a
particle on the right hand
side coming in this way.
So that's a different
scattering experiment.
So in particular,
coming in from the left
means d equals 0 and
a not equal to 0.
Coming in from the right
means a equals 0 and d
not equal to 0 by
exactly the same token.
Cool?
So I want to emphasize this.
a and d, when you think of
this as a scattering process, a
and d are in guys.
In, in.
And c and b are out.
This term corresponds to
moving away from the barrier,
this term corresponds to
just on the left
or on the right.
OK?
Out and out.
Everyone happy with that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: According to that
graph, if d is-- no, that one.
Yeah.
If d is bigger than [INAUDIBLE]
then the transplants will be 1.
Doesn't that mean
that d is also 0?
PROFESSOR: So this is
the classical prediction.
I've written it,
classical prediction.
So let me rephrase.
The question was
basically, look,
that classical
prediction implies
that b must be 0 on the
other scattering process,
and that doesn't sound right.
So is that true?
No, it's not true, and we'll
see it again in a second.
So very good intuition.
That was good.
OK, good.
So in general, if we have
a general wave function,
general superposition of the
two states with energy e with
a,b,c, and d all
non-0, that's fine.
That just corresponds
to sending some stuff
in from the right and
some stuff in-- sorry,
some stuff in from the left and
some stuff in from the right.
Yeah?
But it's, of course,
going to be easier
if we can just do a
simpler experiment.
If we send in stuff
from the left or send in
stuff from the right.
And if we solve those
problems independently,
we can then just
superpose the results
to get the general solution.
Yeah.
So it will suffice
to always either set
d to 0 or a to 0,
corresponding to sending things
in from the left or sending
things in from the right.
And then we can just take
a general superposition
to get the general answer.
Everyone happy with that?
So let's do that in this set up.
So here's our wave function.
And you guys are now adept at
solving the energy eigenvalue
equation, it's just the matching
conditions for a,b,c, and d.
I'm not going to
solve it for you,
I'm just going to
write down the results.
So the results-- in fact,
I'll use a new border.
The results for this guy,
now for e greater than v,
are that-- doo doo doo,
what just happened.
Right, OK, good.
So let's look at the case
d equal 0 corresponding
to coming in from the left.
So in the case of
in from the left,
c is equal to 2k1
over k1 plus k2,
and b is equal to k1
minus k2 over k1 plus k2.
And this tells us, running
through the definition of j,
the currents, and t and r, gives
us that, at the end of the day,
the reflection coefficient is
equal to k1 minus k2 upon k1
plus k2 [INAUDIBLE] squared,
whereas the transmission
amplitude or probability
is equal to 4k1 k2 over k1
plus k2 squared.
And a good exercise for
yourself is to re-derive this,
you're going to have to do that
on the problem set as a warm
up for a problem.
So at this point
we've got an answer,
but it's not terribly satisfying
because k1 and k2, what's
the-- so let's put
this in terms of a more
easily interpretable form.
k1 and k2 are nothing other
than code for the energy
and the energy
minus the potential.
Right, so we must be able to
rewrite this purely in terms
of the energy in the
potential e and v. In fact,
if we go through and
divide both top and bottom
by k1 squared for
both r and t, this
has a nice expression
in terms of the ratio
of the potential to the energy.
And the nice expression is
1 minus the square root of 1
minus v0 over e over
1 plus the square root
of 1 minus v0 over
e norm squared.
And suddenly, the
transmission amplitude
has the form 4 root 1
minus v0 over e over 1
plus the square root of 1
minus v0 over e squared.
I don't remember which
version of the notes
I posted for this year's course.
In the version from
2011 there is a typo
that had here e over v, and
in the version from 2012, that
was corrected in the
notes to being v0 over e.
So I'll check, but let me
just warn you about that.
On one or two pages of
the notes, at some point,
these guys were inverted
with respect to each other.
But the reason to
write this out is now
we can plot the following.
We can now plot the quantum
version of this plot.
We can plot the actual
quantum transmission
as a function of energy,
and the classical prediction
was that at energy
is equal to v0,
we should have a step function.
But now you can see that
this is not a step function,
and that's related to the fact
that b was not actually 0,
as you pointed out.
Hold on one sec.
Sorry, was it quick?
AUDIENCE: The notes are wrong.
PROFESSOR: OK, the notes
are wrong, good, thank you.
That's great.
OK, so the notes are wrong.
It should be v0 over e,
not e over v0 on the notes
that are posted.
We're in the process
of teching them up,
so eventually a beautiful set
of nice notes will be available.
Extra elbow grease.
OK.
So what do we actually see?
Here we got for e
less than v0, we
got in d that the transmission
probability was exactly 0.
So that's a result for
the quantum result.
But when e is equal
to v0, what do we get?
Well, when e is equal
to v0, this is 1.
And we get square
root of 1 minus 1,
which is square root of
0, over square root of 1
plus square root of 1
minus 1, which is 0.
That's 0 over-- OK, good.
So that's not so bad.
Except for this 1 over this e,
this is a little bit worrying.
If you actually
plot this guy out,
it does this, where
it asymptotes to 1.
And to see that it
asymptotes to 1,
to see that it asymptotes
to 1, just take e0 gigantic.
If you know it's gigantic,
this becomes v0 over e,
which goes to 0, and if e is
much larger than the potential.
So this becomes
square root of 1.
And in the denominator, this
becomes square root of 1, 1
plus 1, that's 2 squared, 4, 4
divided by 4, that goes to 1.
So for large e much larger
than v0, this goes to 1.
So we do recover the
classical prediction
if we look at energy
scales very large
compared to the
potential height.
Yeah?
OK.
So that's nice.
Another thing
that's nice to note
is that if you take this
reflection probability
and this transmission
probability,
then they sum up to 1.
This turns out to
be a general fact
and it's a necessary
condition in order for those
to be interpretable
as reflection
in transition probabilities.
The probability
that it transmits
and the probability that it
reflects had better add to 1,
or something is eating
your particles, which
is probably not what
you're looking for.
So this turns out to be true
in this case, just explicitly.
But you can also, as you
will in your problem set,
prove that from that definition
r and t, it's always true.
A check on the sensibility
of our definition.
If it weren't true,
it wouldn't tell you
that quantum
mechanics is wrong, it
would tell you that we
chose a stupid definition
of the transmission and
reflection probabilities.
So in this case, we actually
chose quite an enlightened one.
OK, questions at this point?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does
this analysis even
hold for classical particles?
If we're talking about the
difference between-- like
if I threw a baseball and
I happened to throw it
at a potential that had height
one millionth of a joule
less than the energy
of the baseball,
would we observe this also?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: No?
PROFESSOR: No, for
the following reason.
So here's my classical system.
Classical system is
literally some hill.
So where I was
growing up as a kid,
there was a hill not
far from our house.
I'm not even going to go
into it, but it was horrible.
If you have energy just
ever so slightly greater
than the hill-- he said
from some experience--
if you have energy that's
ever so slightly greater-- OK.
I'm going resist the temptation.
So one of these days.
If you have ever so slightly
greater than the hill,
and you start up here,
what does that tell you?
What does it mean to
say you have energy
just ever so slightly greater
than the potential energy
at that point?
AUDIENCE: Up more slowly.
PROFESSOR: Little tiny velocity.
OK, and I'm going to say I
have a little tiny velocity
this way.
OK.
So what happens?
We follow Newton's equations.
They are totally unambiguous,
and what they tell you is,
with 100% certainty, this thing
will roll and roll and roll,
and then all hell
will break loose.
And then if you're
very lucky, your car
gets caught in the trees on
the side of the cliff, which
is later referred to by the
policeman who helps you tow it
out as nature's guard rail.
I was young, it
won't happen again.
And So with 100% certainty,
Newton's equations
send you right off the cliff.
And for style points, backward.
So now I'm going to
do the second thing.
Newton's laws satisfy
time reversal invariance.
So the time reversal of
this is, this thing has
this much energy, and
it shoots up the cliff.
And ever so slowly,
it just eventually
goes up to the top,
where everything is fine.
OK, but does it ever
reflect back downhill?
No.
And does it ever--
classically, when
you roll the thing--
does it ever actually not
go off the cliff
and hit the trees,
but instead reflect backwards.
I wish the answer were yes.
But sadly, the answer is no.
Now, if that car had been
quantum mechanically small,
my insurance would have
been much more manageable.
But sadly, it wasn't.
OK, so this is a pretty
stark and vivid-- this
is a pretty stark difference
between the quantum
mechanical prediction and
the classical prediction.
Everyone cool with that?
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I understand why
it works out that r plus t
equals 1, but I'm
not sure I understand
the motivation to use the
square with the ratios.
PROFESSOR: Excellent, OK.
So the reason to do it,
so great, excellent.
How to say.
Here's one way to
think about it.
The first thing
we want is we want
a-- so this is a
very good question,
let me repeat the question.
The question is, look,
why is it squared?
Why isn't it linear?
So let's think about that.
Ah, ah, ah.
The reason it's squared
is because of a typo.
So let's think about--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Let's
step back for second
and let's think, OK, it's
a very good question.
So let's think about
what it should be.
OK.
For the moment, put an
arbitrary power there.
OK.
And let's think about
what it should be.
Thank you so much
for this question.
I owe you, like, a plate
of cheese or something.
That's high praise, guys.
France, cheese.
So should it be linear or
should it be quadratic?
What is that supposed
to represent?
What is T, the capital
T, supposed to represent?
AUDIENCE: The probability
of transmission.
PROFESSOR: The probability
of transmission, exactly.
The wave function.
Is the wave function,
the value of the wave
function at some point,
is that a probability?
It's a--
AUDIENCE: Probability
of density.
No, it's the square root.
PROFESSOR: Is it a
probability of density?
It is a probability amplitude.
It is a thing whose norm
squared is a probability.
So we want something that's
quadratic in the wave function,
right.
Meanwhile, some time before,
we wanted a definition
of how much stuff is moving
past a point in the given
moment in time.
What's the probability
density moving past a point
at a given moment in time.
And that's where we got the
current j from the first place.
j was the probability
density moving past a point
at a given moment in time.
So notice that j is quadratic
in the wave function,
so it's how much stuff is moving
past any particular direction--
we chose it to be the incident
to the reflected bit--
at a moment in time.
So it's a probability density--
it's actually a current--
and it's quadratic
in the wave function.
So it has the right units
and the right structure
to be a probability.
If we squared that, we would be
in trouble, because it wouldn't
be a probability, it would
be a probability squared.
And in particular, it
wouldn't normalize correctly.
So that typo was
actually a bad typo.
So what happened, now
thinking back to-- you
have a video someday,
so you can scroll back.
What happened was I didn't
put the squared on the first,
I put the squared on the
second, and then someone said
squared on the first?
Like, yes.
But the correct answer is
no squared on the second.
So there are no squareds.
Thank you for the question.
Very good question.
In particular,
the thing that was
so awesome about
that question was it
was motivated by physics.
It was like, look, why is this
thing squared the right thing?
That's two factors
of the wave function,
it's already quadratic.
It should be like a probability.
Why are you squaring it?
Very good question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in the
transmission probability,
why do we know it's 0 if
the energy is less than v0?
I mean, is there any rule?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, good.
We'll come back to that
question in a little bit,
but let me just quickly
say that we calculated it,
and we see explicitly
that it's 0.
Now you might say well,
look, the true wave function
has a little bit of a tail.
So there's some
[INAUDIBLE] probability
you'll find it here if
you do a measurement.
But the question we want
to ask in transmission
is, if you send it in
from far away over here,
how likely are you to catch
it far away over here?
And the answer is, you are not.
That make sense?
OK, good.
OK, so so much for that one.
Now, here's a fun
fact, I'm not going
to go through this
in any detail.
We could have done exactly
the same calculation-- OK,
we could have done
the same calculation
sending something
in from the right.
And sending something in from
the right, in on the right,
corresponds to d not
equal to 0 and nothing
coming in from the
left, that's a equals 0.
So we could have done
the case a equals 0,
which is in from the right.
And if you do that
calculus, what you find
is c is equal to k1 minus
k2 upon k1 plus k2 d.
And b is equal to 2k1
upon k1 plus k2 d.
And this says that
plugging these guys in,
the reflection and the
transmission are the same.
In particular, physically,
what does that mean?
That means the reflection
and transmission
are the same uphill as downhill.
Downhill is uphill,
they're the same both ways.
But that's truly weird, right?
What's the probability to
transmit quantum mechanically
if you have just a
little bit of energy
and you send the particle in?
How likely are you
to go off the cliff.
If we have energy ever so
slightly greater the potential,
and the transmission
amplitude is the same downhill
as it was uphill, how likely are
you to fall off the potential?
AUDIENCE: Always.
PROFESSOR: Never.
Because if energy is just
slightly greater than v0,
then the transmission
probability is very, very low.
The transmission to
go from here to here
is extremely low
if the energy is
close to the height
of the barrier.
So had I only been on a
quantum mechanical hill,
I would have been just fine.
This is a really
striking result,
but this thing, the
fact that you're
unlikely to scatter uphill,
that's maybe not so shocking.
But you're really unlikely
to scatter downhill,
that is surprising.
So I'll leave it to you
to check that, in fact,
the transmission, when we
do it in from the right,
the transmission and reflection
probabilities are the same.
Recalling that transmission
means going this way,
reflection means bouncing
back to the right.
Cool?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Uh, because, again.
Jeez, today is just a disaster.
Because there's a typo.
This should be times a.
God.
And the reason you know it
should be times a, first off,
is that these should have
the appropriate dimensions.
So there should be an
appropriate power of a.
And the second thing is that
if you double this stuff in,
you'd better double
this stuff out.
So if you double a,
you'd better double c.
So you know there had better
be a factor of a here.
And that's just a typo again.
I'm sorry, today is a bad
day at the chalkboard.
Thank you for that question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a physical reason
for why r and t are the same
and so different from what
you would classically expect,
or is that just the way the math
works?
PROFESSOR: There is.
I want you to ponder that,
and either at the end of today
or at the beginning
of tomorrow, we'll
talk about that
more in detail when
we've done a little
more technology.
It's a good question
and you should
have that tingling
sensation in your belly
that something is
confusing and surprising
and requires more explanation,
and we'll get there.
But I want you to just think
about it in the background
first.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
physical experiment
where r and t don't sum up to 1?
PROFESSOR: Mm mm.
Nope.
So the question is, is
there any experiment
in which r and t
don't sum up to 1?
And there are two
ways to answer that.
The first way to answer
that is, it turns out
that r and t adding up to 1
follows from the definitions.
So one of the things you'll
do on the problem set
is you'll show that using these
definitions of the transmission
and reflection of
probabilities, they necessarily
add up to 1, strictly.
They have to.
It follows from the
Schrodinger equation.
The second answer
is, let's think
about what it would mean if
r and t didn't add up to 1.
If r and t didn't
add up to 1, then
that would say,
look, if you throw
a particle at a barrier, at
some feature in a potential,
some wall, then the
probability that it
goes this way at the end
versus the probability
that it goes that way at the
end if you wait long enough
is not 1.
So what could have happened?
What could have
gotten stuck in there?
But that doesn't even
conserve momentum,
not even approximately.
And we know that the
expectation of momentum
is time independent
for a free particle.
In between while it's
actually in the potential,
it's not actually
time independent,
there's a potential,
there's a force.
AUDIENCE: I mean, if it's whole
particles, can't some of them
get annihilated or something?
PROFESSOR: Ah, well OK.
So if you're talking
about multiple particles
and interactions amongst
multiple particles,
then it's a slightly more
complicated question.
The answer there
is still yes, it
has to be that the
total probability in
is the total probability out.
But we're only going to talk
about single particles here.
But it's always true
that for-- we're
going to take this
as an assumption,
that things don't
just disappear,
that the number of particles
or the total probability
is conserved.
There's a third way to
say this, this really
isn't independent
from the first.
Remember that these were
defined in terms of the current?
The current satisfies--
the current concept
of probability conservation
equation dt of rho
is equal to the gradient minus
the gradient of the current.
So the probability
is always conserved,
the integral of probability
density is always conserved,
it's time independent.
AUDIENCE: So it's
by [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's by construction.
Exactly.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Looking at your
expression for the transition
probability, I'm having trouble
seeing how that works out to 0
when e is less than v0?
PROFESSOR: Oh, this
expression is only
defined when e is equal to v0.
Because we derived this--
excellent question--
we derived this assuming that
we had an energy greater than v0
and then that the wave
function had this form.
You cannot use this form of the
wave function if the energy is
less than v0.
If the energy is
less than v0, you've
got use that form of
the wave function.
And in this form of
the wave function,
we derived that the
transition amplitude is 0,
because the current on the
right, the transmitted current,
is 0.
So this calculation
is appropriate
when e is less than v0 and
this calculation is appropriate
when e is greater than v0.
So you're absolutely correct.
You can't use this
one e is less than v0,
it gives you not
the same answer.
In fact, it gives
you a complex--
it's kind of confusing.
The factors cancel.
So it's not really a
probability at all,
and indeed, this is just not
the right quantity to use.
AUDIENCE: All right, cool.
PROFESSOR: Cool?
All right.
So there are a
bunch of nice things
I want to deduce from
what we've done so far.
So the first is,
look, I pointed out
that this can be
derived just explicitly
and it gives the same
results as before.
That's not an accident.
If you take this
system and you just
reverse the roles of k1
and k2, what happens?
Well that's just
replaces e by e minus v0,
we can do that by doing this,
replacing e by e minus v0
and e minus v0 by e, it
swaps the role of a and d,
and it gives you exactly
the same things back.
So if you're careful
about that, you never
have to do this calculation.
You can just do the
appropriate transformation
on that calculation and it gives
you the exactly the same thing.
It's the same algebraic steps.
But the other thing
that's nice is
that you can actually do
the same thing from here.
So as long as you
set the d equals 0--
so there's another term
here that we neglected,
the plus delta x,
we got rid of it.
But you can analytically
continue this calculation
by noting that look,
if we just set alpha,
we want minus alpha
equals ik2, then
the algebra is all
going to be the same.
We just have ik2
instead of minus alpha.
So we can just replace
alpha with minus ik2
everywhere in our
expressions, being
careful about
exactly how we do so,
being careful to
take care of factors
of i and such correctly.
And you derive the same
results for both cases, which
is a nice check on
the calculation.
So often, when you get a little
bit of experience with these,
you don't actually have
to do the calculation.
Again, you can
just take what you
know from a previous
calculation and write down
the correct answer.
So it's a fun
thing to play with,
exactly how do you do that.
So I invite you to think
through that process
while you're doing
your problem set.
Another thing is the
reflection downhill
thing which is
pretty surprising.
But here's the thing that
I really want to emphasize.
What this calculation
shows you is not so much
that-- it's not just that
transmission downhill
is highly unlikely
when the energy is
very close to the height
of the potential barrier.
That's true, but it's not
the most interesting thing
about this calculation.
The most interesting thing about
this calculation, to my mind,
is the fact that from
the detailed shape
of the transmission as
a function of energy,
we can deduce what
the potential is.
Think about what that tells you.
If you do an experiment,
you have a barrier,
and you want to know the
shape of the barrier.
Is it straight,
is it wiggly, does
it have some complicated shape.
How do you measure that?
Well, you might measure
it by just looking.
But imagine you can't,
for some reason.
For whatever, it's in a box
or you can't look at it.
Maybe it's just
preposterously small.
How can you deduce what
the shape of that hill is?
Well, one way to
do it is to send
in particles as a function of
energy, more and more energy,
and measure the probability
that they transmit.
OK.
Now if you do so and you get
this graph as a function of e,
what do you deduce?
You deduce that the barrier
that you're scattering off of
is a square step
with this height v0.
Are we cool with that?
So apparently, just
look at the transmission
amplitudes, the
transition probabilities,
you can deduce at
least something
of the form of the potential.
Which is kind of cool.
If you didn't know
the potential,
you could figure
out what it was.
And this turns out to be a
very general statement that you
can deduce an enormous
amount, and as we'll see,
you can, in fact,
deduce basically
everything you want
of the potential
from knowing about the
transmission probabilities
as well as the phase shift,
the transmission amplitudes.
So this is the basic
goal of scattering.
And so the way I
want you to think
about it is imagine, for
example, that someone
hands you an object.
A box.
And the box has an in port
and it has an out port.
And they allow you
to send in particles
as a function of energy
and measure transmission
and reflection, you can measure
transmission and reflection.
Just like I'm measuring
transmission off of your faces
right now, from the
light from above.
So suppose that you do so, put
it on your test stand and you
measure transmission.
You measure transmission
as a function of energy,
and you observe the following.
The transmission as
a function of energy
is small up until some point,
and then at some point,
which may be the minimum energy
you can meaningfully probe,
you get something like this.
So here's the transmission
as a function of energy.
So what can you say?
If this is all the
information you
have about what's going
on inside the box,
what can you deduce about
the thing inside the box?
One thing you can
deduce is that it
looks kind of like a potential
with height around v0.
It looks kind of like a
potential step with some height
v0.
This is asymptoting to 1.
However, it's not, because it
has these oscillations in it.
So there's more to the potential
than just a barrier of height
v0.
What I want to show you is
that you can deduce everything
about that potential, and
that's the point of scattering.
So let's do it.
So the goal here, again, to say
it differently, is what's v0?
What is v of x?
Not just the height,
but the total potential.
So another way to say
this, let me set up
a precise version
of this question.
I want to be able
to do the following.
I want to take a system that has
a potential which is constant
up to some point
which I'll call 0,
and then again from some
point, which I'll call L,
is constant again.
And inside, I don't know
what the potential is.
So in here, there's
some unknown potential,
v of x, which is
some crazy thing.
It could be doing anything.
It could be some crazy-- it
could have horns and whatever.
It could be awful.
But the potential is constant
if you go far enough away,
and the potential is constant
if you go far enough away.
A good example of this
is a hydrogen atom.
It's neutral but there's
a clearly and complicated
potential inside because
the proton and the electron
are moving around in there in
some quantum state, anyway,
and if you send something
at it, far away, it's
as if it's not there.
But close by, you know there
are strong electrostatic forces.
And so the question is what
you learn about those forces,
what can you learn
about the potential
by throwing things in from
far away, from either side.
Now one thing we know already
is that out here, the wave
function always-- because it's
a constant potential-- always
takes the form e to the ikx
plus b e to the minus ikx.
And out here it takes the
form c e to the ikx plus d
e to the minus ikx.
And again, this
corresponds to moving in.
d is in from the right.
c is out to the right.
b is out to the left.
And a is in from the left.
So again, there are
basically four kind
of scattering
experiments we can do.
We can send things in
from the right, which
corresponds to setting a to 0.
We can send things in
from the left, which
corresponds to
setting t equal to 0.
And all the information
about what happens in v
is going to be encoded
in what's coming out,
the b and c coefficients.
And the way to make
that sharp is just
to notice that the transmission
probability, if we compute
for this system, assuming
it's forming the wave function
asymptotically away from the
potential, the transmission
amplitude is just
c over a squared
when you're sending
in from the left.
And the reflection is equal
to b over a norm squared.
This squared is a squared.
[INAUDIBLE] function over
amplitude squared, good.
To learn about the transmission
and reflection coefficients,
it's enough-- suffices--
to compute, to know b and c
as a function of a and d.
All of the scattering
information
is in those coefficients
b and c for a and d.
And here I'm assuming that I'm
sending in a monochromatic wave
with a single, well
defined energy.
I'm sending in a beam of
particles with energy e.
I don't know where
they are, but I sure
know what their momentum is.
So some well defined beam
of particles with energy e.
And these
probabilities are going
to contain all the data I want.
So this is the basic
project of scattering.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So basically,
it only depends
on the transmission-- it
only depends on the edges?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
The question is, does the
transmission depend only
on what you do with the edges.
And here's the important thing.
The transmission
depends crucially
on what happens in here.
For example, if this is an
infinitely high barrier,
nothing's going across.
So this transmission
depends on what's in here.
But the point is we can deduce
just by looking far away,
we can deduce the
transmission probability
and amplitude just by
measuring b and c far away,
b and c far away.
OK.
So the transmission
amplitude is something
you measure when very far away.
You measure-- if I throw
something in from very far
out here to the left, how likely
is it to get out here very
far to the right?
And in order to answer
that, if someone
hands you the
answer to that, they
must have solved
for what's inside.
That the point.
So knowing the answer
to that question
encodes information about
what happened in between.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
initially, your potential's
going to-- so say it's
stuff you did earlier.
The potential drops down to
the [INAUDIBLE] in the box.
Is that going to be problematic?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
for simplicity, I'm
going to assume that the
potential always goes to 0 when
we're far away, because that's
going to be useful for modeling
things like hydrogen
and, exactly.
Carbon, we're going
to do diamond later
in the semester,
that'll be useful.
But we could repeat
this analysis
by adding an extra change
in the asymptotic potential,
it doesn't really change
anything important.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It looks like even
for just the simple step up
[INAUDIBLE] you can't tell
from just the probabilities why
the step is going
up or going down.
PROFESSOR: Ah, excellent.
Excellent, excellent.
So good, thank you for that
question, that's really great.
So already, it seems
like we can't uniquely
identify the potential from
the transmission probability
if the transmission probability
is the same for step up
or step down.
So what's missing?
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
energy [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But we're working
with an energy [INAUDIBLE].
So the energy is just
a global constant.
We'll see what's
missing, and what's
missing is something
called the phase shift.
So very good question, yes.
AUDIENCE: It looks like when we
did the example for the step,
that t equals [INAUDIBLE]
over a squared.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it is,
because it's the ratio.
That's why I wrote
t is c over here.
So t is the ratio of j over ji.
And in fact, jt here is
equal to c squared times--
so this is the
probability density,
so it's the probability density
times the velocity, what's
the effect of velocity here?
H bar k 2 over m, whereas
j incident is equal
to a squared--
probability density
times the momentum there,
the velocity there--
which is h bar k1 upon m.
So here the ratio of j
transmitted to j incident
is norm c squared k2
over norm a squared k1.
AUDIENCE: So because
it's not level--
PROFESSOR: Exactly, it's
because it's not level.
So here, they
happen to be level,
so they're only
[INAUDIBLE] factor, cancel,
and the only thing that
survives is the amplitude.
Good question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For the
lead box example,
is it sufficient
just to know what's
reflected back to
solve the situation?
PROFESSOR: So for
precisely for this reason,
it's not sufficient to know t.
It's not sufficient
to know t and r.
But, of course, once
you know r, you know t,
so you're exactly right.
Once you know the
reflection probability,
you know the
transmission probability,
but there's one more
bit of information
which we're going to
also need in order
to specify the potential, which
is going to be the phase shift.
But you're right, you don't
need to independently compute
r and t, you can
just compute one.
AUDIENCE: You need sensors
on both sides of the box,
to answer my question.
PROFESSOR: You
don't need sensors
on both sides of the box, but
you need to do more than just
do the counting problem.
We'll see that.
OK.
So let's work out a simple
example, the simplest
example of a barrier
of this kind.
We want constant potential,
and then ending at 0,
and we want a constant again
from L going off to infinity.
So what's the easiest
possible thing we could do?
Step, step.
We're just doing what
we've done before twice.
So this is an example of
this kind of potential.
It's sort of ridiculously
simple, but let's work it out.
So we want scattering,
let's start out,
we could do either
scattering from the left
or scattering from the right.
Let's start out scattering
from the left, so d equals 0,
and let's study this problem.
So what we know--
and let's also note
that we have a choice to make.
We could either study
energy below the height
of the potential or
we can study energy
above the height
of the potential.
And so for simplicity,
I'm also going
to start with energy
greater than the height
of the potential, v0, and
then we'll do e less than v0
afterwards.
It'll be an easy extension
of what we've done.
OK, so this will be our
first case to study.
So we know the form of the
wave function out here,
it's a e to the ikx,
b to the minus ikx.
We know that for the
potential out here
it's c e to the ikx and
d e to the minus ikx.
The only thing we
don't know is the form
of the potential in here.
And in here it's
actually very simple.
It's got to be something
of the form-- I
think I called it
f and g, I did.
f e to the ik prime
x-- I'm calling this k,
so I'll just call this
k prime x-- plus g
e to the minus ik prime x.
And the reason I
chose k prime is
because we're working
with energy greater
than the potential, so this is
a classically allowed region.
It's an oscillatory domain
but with a different k prime.
So here, k squared, h bar
squared over 2m is equal to e,
and h bar squared k
prime squared over 2m
is equal to e minus
v0, which is positive
when e is greater than v0.
This analysis will not obtain
when e is less than v0,
we'll have to treat
it separately.
So now what do we do?
We do the same thing we did
before, we just do it twice.
We'll do the matching
conditions here,
the matching conditions here.
That's going to give us 1,
2, 3, 4 matching conditions.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 unknown coefficients,
so we'll have two
independent ones.
That's great.
We set d equal to 0
to specify that it's
coming in from the left and
not from the right, that's 5.
And then we have
normalization, which is 6,
so this should uniquely
specify our wave function.
Yeah.
Once we've fixed e, we
have enough conditions.
So I'm not going to go
through the derivation
because it's just an extension
of what we did for the first.
It's just a whole
bunch of algebra.
And let me just emphasize this.
The algebra is not interesting.
It's just algebra.
You have to be
able to do it, you
have to develop some
familiarity with it,
and it's easy to
get good at this.
You just practice.
It's just algebra.
But once you get the idea,
don't ever do it again.
Once you get
reasonably quick at it,
learn to use Mathematica, Maple,
whatever package you want,
and use computer algebra
to check your analysis.
And use your physics
to check the answer
you get from Mathematica or
Maple or whatever you use.
Always check against
physical reasonability,
but use Mathematica.
So posted on the website
are Mathematica files
that walk through the
computation of the transmission
and reflection amplitudes
and probabilities
for this potential, and I
think maybe another one,
I don't remember exactly.
But I encourage you strongly
to use computer algebra tools,
because it's just
a waste of time
to spend three hours doing
an algebra calculation.
In particular, on your
problem set this week,
you will do a scattering problem
similar to the bound state
probably you did last week, the
quantum glue problem-- which
you may be doing tonight,
the one due tomorrow.
Which is two delta
function wells
and find the bound
states, so that
involves a fair
amount of algebra.
The scattering
problem will involve
a similar amount of algebra.
Do not do it.
Use Mathematica or
computer algebra
just to simplify your life.
So if we go through and
compute the-- so what
are we going to do, we're
going to use the matching
conditions here to determine
f and g in terms of a and b,
then we'll use the
matching conditions here
to determine c-- d is 0--
c in terms of f and g.
So that's going to give us an
effective constraint relating
a and b, leaving us with an
overall unknown coefficient
a, which we'll use
for normalization.
The upshot of all of
which is the answers
are that, I'm not even going
to write down-- they're
in the notes.
Should I write this down?
I will skip.
So the upshot is that the
transmission amplitude,
as a function of k and k prime--
the transmission probability, I
should say, is 1
over-- actually,
I'm going to need
the whole amplitude.
Shoot.
The transmission
probability is equal to--
and this is a horribly
long expression--
the transmission probability,
which is c over a norm squared,
is equal to 4 k squared k prime
squared cosine squared of k
prime l plus k squared plus
k prime squared sine squared
of k prime l under 4k
squared k prime squared.
Seriously.
So we can simplify this out,
so you can do some algebra.
This is just what
you get when you just
naively do the algebra.
I want to do two things.
First off, this is horrible.
There's a cosine squared,
there's a sine squared,
surely we can all be
friends and put it together.
So let's use some trig.
But the second thing, and
the more important thing,
is I want to put this
in dimensionless form.
This is horrible.
Here we have ks and we have ls,
and these all have dimensions,
and they're inside the sines
and the cosines it's kl.
That's good, because this
has units of one over length,
this has units of length,
so that's dimensions.
Let's put everything
in dimensionless form.
And in particular, what are
the parameters of my system?
The parameters of my system
are, well, there's a mass,
there's an h bar, there's a
v0, and then there's an energy,
and there's a length l.
So it's easy to make a
dimensionless parameter out
of these guys, and a
ratio of energies--
a dimensionless ratio of
energies-- out of these guys.
So I'm going to do that, and
the parameters I'm going to use
are coming from here.
I'm going to define the
parameters g0 squared, which
is a dimensionless measure of
the depth of the potential.
We've actually run
into this guy before.
2m l squared v0
over h bar squared.
So this is h bar squared, 1 over
l squared is k squared over 2m,
so that's an energy.
So this is a ratio of the
height of the potential
to the characteristic energy
corresponding to length scale
l.
So the width, there's an
energy corresponding to it
because you take a momentum
which has 1 over that width.
You can build an energy out of
that h bar k squared over 2m.
And we have an energy which
is the height of the barrier,
we take the ratio of those.
So that's a dimensionless
quantity, g0.
And the other dimensionless
quantity I want to consider
is a ratio of the
energy, e, to v0,
which is what showed up
before in our energy plot.
Or in our transmission
plot over there, e over v0.
So when we take this and we
do a little bit of algebra
to simplify our life, again, use
Mathematica, it's your friend.
The result is much
more palatable.
It's t-- again, for the
energy greater than v0--
is equal to, still long.
But 1 plus 1 over 4 epsilon,
epsilon minus 1 sine
squared of g0 square
root of epsilon minus 1.
And upstairs is a one.
So remember this is only
valid for e greater than v0,
or equivalently,
epsilon greater than 1.
And I guess we can
put an equal in.
So when you get an
expression like this,
this is as easy as you're
going to make this expression.
It's not going to
get any easier.
It's 1 over a sine
times a function plus 1.
There's really no great
way to simplify this.
So what you need when you
get an expression like this
is try to figure out
what it's telling you.
The useful thing to
do is to plot it.
So let's just look
at this function
and see what it's telling us.
Let's plot this t as
a function of epsilon
and for some fixed g0.
Keep in mind that this only
makes sense for e greater
than v0 or for epsilon
greater than 1, so here's 1.
And we're going
to remain agnostic
as to what happens below 1.
And just for normalization,
we know that the transmission
probability can never
be greater than 1,
so it's got to be
between 1 and 0.
So here's 0 and 0.
We're remaining agnostic
about this for the moment.
So let's start thinking about
what this plot looks like.
First off, what does
it look like at 1?
So when epsilon
goes to 1, this is
going to 0, that's bad
because it's in a denominator.
But upstairs, this
is going to 0,
and sine squared of something
when it's becoming small
goes like-- well, sine
goes like that thing.
So sine squared goes like
this quantity squared.
So sine squared goes
like g0 squared,
this goes like 1
over-- this is going
like g0 squared epsilon
minus 1 square root quantity
squared, which is
epsilon minus 1.
So this is going to 0 and
this, the denominator,
is going to 0 exactly
in the same way.
Epsilon minus 1 from
here, epsilon minus 1
downstairs from here.
So the epsilon minus
ones precisely cancel.
From the sine squared
we get a g0 squared,
and from here we
get a 4 epsilon.
So we get 1 plus g0
squared over 4 epsilon.
But 4 epsilon, what
was epsilon here?
1.
We're looking at
epsilon goes to 1,
so this is just
g0 squared over 4.
So the height, the value of t--
so we're not looking in here.
But at energy is equal to
v0 or epsilon is equal to 1,
we know that the transmission
amplitude is not 0,
but it's also strictly
smaller than 1.
Which is good,
because if it were 6,
you'd be really worried.
So g0 squared, if g0 squared
is 0, what do we get?
1.
Fantastic, there's no barrier.
We just keep right on going
through, perfect transmission.
If g0 is not zero, however,
the transmission is suppressed.
Like 1 over g0 squared.
What does this actually
look like with some value.
And what is this value,
it's just 1 over 1
plus 1/4 g0 squared.
Cool?
OK.
And now what
happens, for example,
for a very large epsilon?
Well, when epsilon is gigantic,
sine squared of this-- well,
sine squared is
oscillating rapidly,
so that's kind of worrying.
If this is very,
very large, this
is a rapidly
oscillating function.
However, it's being divided
by roughly epsilon squared.
So something that goes between
0 and 1 divided by epsilon
squared, as epsilon
gets large, becomes 0.
And so we get 1 over
1 plus 0, we get 1.
So for very large values
it's asymptoting to 1.
So naively, it's going to
do something like this.
However, there's
this sine squared.
And in fact, this
is exactly what
it would do if we just had
the 1 over epsilon times
some constant.
But in fact, we have
the sine squared,
and the sine squared
is making it wiggle.
And the frequency
of the wiggle is g0,
except that it's not
linear in epsilon,
it's linear in square
root of epsilon.
So as epsilon gets larger,
the square root of epsilon
is getting larger
less than linearly.
So what that's telling you is
if you looked at root epsilon,
you would see it
with even period.
But we don't have
root epsilon, we're
plugging this as a
function of epsilon.
So it's not even period,
it's getting wider and wider.
Meanwhile, there's a
nice fact about this.
For special values of epsilon,
what happens to sine squared?
It goes to zero.
And what happens
when this is zero?
Yeah, t is 1.
So every time sine is 0,
i.e., for sufficient values
when root epsilon is a multiple
of pi determined by g0,
transmission goes to 1.
It becomes perfect.
So in fact, instead
of doing-- wow.
Instead of doing this, what
it does is it does this.
So let's check that
I'm not lying to you.
So let me draw it
slightly different.
To check, so it's going to
0, and the period of the 0
is getting further
and further along.
That's because this is
square root, not squared.
So epsilon has to get much
larger to hit the next period.
That's why it's getting
larger and larger spacing.
However, the amplitude
goes down from 1,
that's when this gets largest.
Well, at large values of
epsilon, this is suppressed.
As epsilon goes
larger and larger,
this deviation become
smaller and smaller.
So that's what this
plot is telling us.
This plot is telling
us a bunch of things.
First off, we see that
at large energies,
we transmit perfectly.
That makes sense.
This was a finitely
high barrier.
Large energies, we
don't even notice it.
It tells you at low
energies-- well,
we don't know yet what
happens at very low energies.
But at reasonably low energies,
the transmission is suppressed.
And if you sort of
squint, this roughly
does what we'd expect
from the step barrier.
However, something
really special
is happening at special
values of epsilon.
We're getting
perfect transmission.
We get perfect transmission of
these points, t is equal to 1.
Perfect.
Star.
Happy with a big nose.
I don't know.
Perfect transmission
at all these points.
So this leaves us with
a question of why.
Why the perfect
transmission, what's
the mechanism making
transmission perfect.
But it also does something
really lovely for us.
Suppose you see a spectrum, you
see a transmission amplitude
or transmission probability
that looks like this.
You may get crappy data.
You may see that
it's smudged out
and you see all
sorts of messy stuff.
But if you know that
there's perfect transmission
at some particular
epsilon 1, there's
more perfect transmission at
another epsilon 2, more perfect
transmission at
epsilon 3, and they
scale, they fit to
this prediction.
What do you know?
That you've got a
finite high barrier,
and it's probably pretty well
approximated by a square step.
So in your problem set, you're
going to get experimental data,
and you're going to have to
match to the experimental data.
You're going to have
to predict something
about the potential that created
a particular transmission
probability distribution.
And knowing where
these resonances are,
where these points of
perfect transmission,
is going to be very
useful for you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't there
another potential
that will also
create periodic 1s?
PROFESSOR: A very good question.
So I'm going to turn
that around to you.
Can you orchestrate a potential
that gives you the same thing?
That's an interesting
empirical question.
So, on the problem set, you'll
study a double well potential.
So the question
was, how do I know
isn't another potential that
gives me the same answer?
At this point, we don't know.
Maybe there is
another potential.
In fact, you can do
all sorts of things
to make a potential that's
very arbitrarily close that
gives you an arbitrarily
similar profile.
So if they're
significantly different,
how different do they look?
So then the students
say, well, I don't know.
What about a double
well potential?
So, in fact, we'll be doing
a double well potential
on the problem set.
A good question.
And we certainly
haven't proven anything
like this is the
only potentially
that gives you this
transmission amplitude.
What we can say is if you get
transmission amplitude that
looks like this, it's
probably pretty reasonable
to say it's probably
well modeled.
We seem to be reproducing
the data reasonably well.
So it's not a proof of
anything, but it's a nice model.
And we're physicists,
we build models.
We don't tell you
what's true, we
tell you what are good models.
If a theorist ever
walks up on you
and he says, here's the
truth, punch him in the gut.
That's not how it works.
Experimentalists,
on the other hand.
We'll just punch
them too, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: We build models.
OK, so this leaves us
with an obvious question,
which we've answer
in the case of energy
grade in the potential.
What about the case of the
energy less than the potential.
So we haven't filled out
that part of the graph.
Let's fill out that
part of the graph.
What happens if the energy
is less than the potential?
And for this, I'm going to
use the trick that I mentioned
earlier that, look,
if the energy is
less than the potential,
that just means that
in the intervening
regime, in here,
instead of being
oscillatory, it's
going to be exponentially
growing [INAUDIBLE]
because we're in a
classically disallowed region.
So if the energy
is less than v0,
here we have instead of
ikx, we have minus alpha x.
And instead of minus ikx
we have plus alpha x.
So if you go through
that whole analysis
and plug in those values for
the k prime, the answer you get
is really quite nice.
We find that t for energy
less than v0 is equal to--
and it's just a direct
analytic continuation of what
you get here-- 1 plus 1 over
4 epsilon 1 minus epsilon.
So epsilon is less than 1 now.
1 sinh squared of g0 1
minus epsilon under 1.
OK, so now this lets
us complete the plot.
And you can check, it's
pretty straightforward,
that because sinh, again,
goes like its argument
at very small values
of its argument,
we get g0 squared
1 minus epsilon.
Sorry, this should be
square root 1 minus epsilon.
Really?
Is that a typo?
Oh no, it's in there.
OK, good.
So again, we get g0
squared 1 minus epsilon,
the 1 minus epsilon cancels,
and we get 1 over 4 g0 squared.
Which is good, because
if they disagreed,
we'd be in real trouble.
So they agree, but the sinh
squared is just a strictly--
or that function is just
a strictly decreasing
function as we approach
epsilon goes to 0.
It goes mostly to 0.
So this is what we see.
We see an exponential
region and then
we see oscillations
with residences
where the period is
getting wider and wider.
But this should trouble
you a little bit.
Here, what are we saying?
We're saying look,
if we have a barrier,
and we send in a
particle with energy way
below the barrier,
that's kind of troubling.
If we send in a particle with
energy way below the barrier,
there's some probability
that it gets out.
It goes across.
So for e less than v0,
classically no transmission,
we get transmission.
Now, do we get resonances
when e is less than v0?
No, that's an interesting thing.
We'll talk about resonances
and where they come from,
and we'll talk about the more
generalized notion of a nest
matrix in the next lecture.
But for now I just want to say
a couple of things about it.
So I want to ask-- so
this is called tunneling,
this transmission across
a disallowed barrier,
a classically
disallowed barrier--
so this transmission
across a disallowed barrier
is called tunneling.
And just a quick thing to notice
is that if we hold e fixed
and we vary l, we vary
the width of the barrier,
how does the tunneling
amplitude depend
on the width of the barrier?
At fixed energy, if we vary the
width of the barrier-- which
is only contained
in g0-- how does
the transmission amplitude vary?
And we find that for large
l-- for l much greater than 1
for a typical scale
in the problem--
the tunneling amplitude goes
like e to the minus 2 alpha l
where alpha just depends on
the energy in the potential.
So what we see is that the
probability of transmitting,
of tunneling through
a wall, depends
on the width of that wall.
And it depends on
it exponentially.
The wider the wall, the
exponentially less likely you
are to tunnel across it.
And this fits the
simulation we ran
where we saw that tunnelling
through a very thin wall
was actually quite efficient.
And we also saw that
tunnelling across a wall
can have resonant peaks.
At special values, it
transmits perfectly.
We saw that in the simulations.
So at this point I can't resist
telling you a very short story.
I have a very good friend
who is not a physicist,
but who is a professor at MIT.
So a smart person,
and very smart.
She's one of the
smartest people I know.
She broke her ankle.
She's always losing stuff,
she's constantly losing stuff.
And she broke her ankle, and she
was going to the rehab place,
and she parked her car right
in front of the rehab place.
She parked her
car right in front
because she's got
the broken ankle
and she doesn't want to have to
walk a long way to get the car,
she parked right in front.
She went in, she did
her two hours of rehab,
and she came outside,
and her car was gone.
And she's always
misplacing her car,
she's always
misplacing her keys,
she's always losing everything.
But this time, this time
she knew where it was.
And it wasn't there.
So first she thought, oh
crap, my car's been stolen.
How annoying, I've
got a broken ankle.
But she looks
around, and there's
her car on the other side
of the street pointed
the opposite direction.
And she's like, finally.
Finally.
She was explaining this to
me and a friend of mine who
is also a physicist,
she said finally, I
knew I had incontrovertible
proof that quantum
effects happen to
macroscopic objects.
My car tunnelled
across the street.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: At this
point, of course,
my friend and I are
just dying of laughter.
But she said my car
tunnelled across the street.
But here's the problem,
I couldn't tell anyone.
Because if I told anyone, they
would know that I was crazy.
Clearly I'm crazy, because I
lose my stuff all the time,
but surely it's just
gotten misplaced.
So I went home, and
I got home and I
was sitting down to dinner with
my partner and our daughter
and I was burning up
inside because I wanted
to tell them this
crazy thing happened.
I know quantum
mechanics, it happens.
I couldn't tell them
anything, so I was just
fidgeting and dying.
And finally my
daughter said, mom,
didn't you notice that we moved
the car across the street?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: See you next time.